Knights at the round table were expected
to adhere to a strict moral standard of
piety honor bravery and courtesy called
chivalry but considering that they often
spent their days killing and rampaging
at the behest of their Lord that must
have required some Next Level
compartmentalization this Duality is
reflected in the various versions of a
key figure who appears in aruan Legends
throughout history sir GNE in some
stories gain is the embodiment of shivel
Excellence he rescues maidens
masterminds quests and and takes out
pirates in others GNE is very much the
anti-hero even inciting the fall of King
Arthur this vacillation of gain's
character is most clearly on display in
what is perhaps the most well-known
Arthurian Legend the 14th century shck
poem sir G and the Green Knight the
story is a generally favorable account
of gain's character but it also lays
bare the ambiguities of his position is
gain's conflicted depiction in the green
KN a criticism of chivalry and heroism
as it was was known at the time Perhaps
it is a commentary on The Human
Condition at
large written anonymously and
rediscovered centuries later serain in
the Green Knight is set at Christmas
time and involves an intruder and that's
where the similarities to Home Alone end
while Arthur and his Knights are
feasting they're interrupted by a giant
Green Knight in green garments riding a
green horse right into the Hall the
Green Knight claims he seeks no violence
only a g he invites someone to strike
him with his own Axe and in return the
volunteer must consent to the Green
Knight striking him in one year and one
day's time so who's it going to be
Arthur is about to rise to the challenge
to save face until the loyal gain steps
in for some reason GNE decides to go big
or go home he rolls a natural 20 and
chops the green Knight's head clean off
game over right well imagine his
surprise when the Green Knight calmly
Scoops up his laughing head in order is
going to find him at the green Chapel
next year where he will repay the blow
it may not sound like something that
would catch on but this game actually
has a name popularized in Celtic and
medieval mythology the beheading game
yes really usually involves a young
Warrior being invited to behead and
submit to a beheading kind of like an
ultra Stakes power slap league in a
famous Irish myth evil Lord Brew invites
three of Ireland's best heroes to dinner
and pits them against each other for
their final challenge a mysterious
Warrior orders them to chop off his head
and come back the next night for him to
return the blow so you want us to chop
your head off yes
please but why I guess you could say I
want to stay ahead of the
game only one of the heroes K Cullen
shout out to our K cullin episode shows
up cementing his status as the
winner guess that makes me Head of the
Class in another Legend Arthur's Knight
kok is obliged to behead a hooded
stranger and submit to a beheading the
beheading game is like the ultimate test
of Honor will you keep your word to play
the game even if it means your death
meanwhile the people on my trivia team
have always some kind of excuse for not
showing up even though I made it very
clear that Pub trivia is a commitment
after a very anxious year GNE must
either stick to the terms of the game or
lose his honor so he rides out to meet
his fate after encountering a variety of
enemies and marbles that are not
described but trust us they were amazing
he arrives at the Grand castle of Lord
and Lady berac the bacs tell him that
he's close to the green Chapel but offer
to let him rest up with them for a few
days gain's in no rush to get his head
chopped off so he happily accepts not
knowing that he's just walked into yet
another bizarre game Lord berac declares
that he will go hunting every day and
share his spoils with gain but in return
gain must give the Lord whatever he's
received during his day at the castle on
the first day lady berac sneaks into
gain's Chambers and attempts to seduce
him he rebuffs her politely with a
chased kiss when the Lord returns from
the hunt he shares a deer with G and
gain gives him a single kiss on the
second day gain permits two kisses from
the lady which he passes on to the Lord
in exchange for a boar on the third day
the lady lavishes gain with three kisses
and something extra I know you think
where you know this is going but I
promise you it's not a magical green and
gold girdle which she promises will
protect him from the green KN when the
Lord returns GNE has a dilemma keeping
the girdle secret would break his
promise but might save his life and
avoid a very awkward conversation like
many mythical Heroes gain is constantly
trying to prove his worth but gets
confused by games with arbitrary rules
and unclear expectations in medieval
times there was a fine line between
games and violence okay still kind of
true dueling and hunting were
recreational but they were also part of
a knight's violent duties by
participating in both a beheading game
and a hunting game gain is
simultaneously navigating the worlds of
violence and Sport and apparently sex
and by accepting The Spoils of the hunt
while keeping the girdle he sacrifices
his honor finally gain arrives at the
green Chapel an uncanny grassy cave and
confronts the Green Knight despite his
fear he kneels at the Giant's feet and
offers his neck as promised the Green
Knight lifts his axe above his head
swings it down at gain's neck but only
next him drawing a few drops of blood G
is in shock but the Green Knight bursts
out laughing and commends gain for
upholding the bargain he reveals himself
to be none other than Lord berac
disguised by the magic of the old
sorceress Morgan Lefay to test Arthur's
knights it was all a prank I guess this
mirrors the ending of other beheading
games in bre crw Feast kullin is spared
on account of his bravery while kodok
story ends with his enemy striking him
with a blunt sword and praising him for
his courage on the one hand these
stories make light of the hero's
struggle by turning a serious bargain
into a courtly just on the other they
can be read as a critique of heroism and
its Hollow violent nature the story of
GNE and the Green Knight shares this
dual meaning it pokes fun at lofty
chivalric standards but it also
interrogates the impossibility of these
standards while gain should be proud of
mostly passing the test he feels like a
coward for breaking his word about the
girdle and arrives back at court in
emotional wreck but luckily he's got his
Round Table Bros to lift him back up as
far as they're concerned he survived a
terrifying ordeal with his reputation
more or less intact they even all start
wearing green and gold girdles to
celebrate him G's our hero thanks does
my epic beard help absolutely yes green
and gold girl crew
[Laughter]
represent Lord and Lady berac have a
really messed up relationship
yeah G's hero status is a Christmas
miracle the Christmas setting is no
accident it highlights another tension
that poor G has to navigate that between
Christian and Pagan worlds a Christian
holiday is literally interrupted by an
explicitly Pagan figure with his green
skin wild beard and bare chest the Green
Knight clearly represents nature and
resembles the mythical Green Man a face
Inc in leaves that appears in ancient
artwork from India to the British Isles
green was also the color of Witchcraft
and the devil and there's something
definitely Supernatural about a giant
who can pick up his own severed head
magic in the form of the girdle is also
what punctures gain's otherwise
watertight honor and yet the test of
gain's honor is only possible because of
sorcery which enables the transformation
of Lord berac into a green giant these
chaotic circumstances reveal the
entanglement of paganism and
Christianity which shaped the medieval
worldview no wonder G's confused gain's
inconsistency can be attributed to his
character or lack thereof the lack of a
significant trait leaves him open to our
projections but it's also what makes him
the most human of Arthur's nights in the
end it's hard not to feel a little sorry
for gain by just trying to do the right
thing he got tricked into volunteering
for beheading made a treacherous Journey
towards his own certain death got sucked
into an Ecentric couple's weird sex
games all to get laughed at by the green
KN still G arguably manages to stay
honorable along the way except for the
girdle but come on who wouldn't want to
keep the girdle later depictions of gain
have shared the sympathy the once in
Future King fantasy novels concoct a
traumatic childhood for gain while the
recent film adaptation the Green Knight
portrays him as a very human Hero trying
to make the best of baffling
circumstances in the comic once in
future aruan Legend is retold in a
modern-day exploration of the power of
Storytelling with G's mantle taken up by
Rose one of the female protagonists
while these expansions to GNE lore in
modern-day mythmaking more explicitly
comment on changing attitudes towards
gender and heroism the internal
conflicts at the core of the narrative
continue to reflect the complexity of
humanity and our brutal world we might
not play the beheading game at parties
anymore but the tension between
entertainment and violence is still very
much a part of culture the legends of
gain are a testament that even a knight
of the Round Table can be susceptible to
pit Falls mistakes and human error not
to mention the hypocrisies of chivalry
which the original Anonymous author seem
to recognize ultimately GNE is a hero
who is Thoroughly shaped by the world
around him his challenge lies in
upholding cultural norms but his power
lies in exposing the cracks and
contradictions that underly those Norms
so if you've been following along for
this season of fate and fabled we're
doing our favorite Pantheon picks so for
my pick for this episode I'm going with
the the Morgan ooh nice choice thank you
the Morgan I just think is really
interesting perspective wise cuz she's
one and many she can also shape shift
into a crow and you know how much I love
birds so the Morgan's my pick yeah that
a great great pick stay tuned for our
next episode you'll get to hear our next
Pantheon pick before you go we want to
hear your feedback every year PBS
digital Studios surveys our audience
helping us understand what you enjoy on
YouTube and what you would want to see
us make more of you also get to vote on
new show ideas so it' be great if fate
and fabled fans were well represented in
the polls there's a link in the
description thanks in
advance whoa do I then fall
over I
left queen and gold
CLE